[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact well it looks like the
religious robots are coming for example
a 400 year old Buddhist temple in Kyoto
Japan has a new priest named mind our he
delivers sermons moves around to
interface with worshipers but mind our
comes with some unusual traits a body
made of aluminum and silicon for
starters yes robot priests are popping
up everywhere
last year in the small German town of
Wittenberg they unveiled a robot priest
that's called bless you - that delivers
blessings in five languages while
screaming beams of light from its hands
during a Hindu festival in India the
Patel automation company hit on the idea
of letting a robot perform the worship
ritual for the elephant head got at it
spoon a facility then there's Santo an
18 inch tall robot that looks like a
generic Catholic saint but it's equipped
with some software it uses to listen to
people scan their faces for signs of
specific emotions and then select
religious texts that might be relevant
to their troubles with a recent
explosion of artificial intelligence it
makes you wonder where do you draw the
line between a smartphone and a
computerized pastor stay with his
friends we're going to learn more on
this edition of Bible answers live
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 seven to
ninety seven to call in with your
questions eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven and you can also
listen at the amazing facts or Doug
Batchelor Facebook page well you can
listen you can watch and if you do
happen to go to Facebook and look at our
stream there you're gonna notice that we
have a little different background
because amazing facts is right now
moving into our new offices in Granite
Bay California and aware we're only
halfway moved in so you're gonna see us
sitting at a kind of a office table here
and doing our radio program with our
laptops and stuff but we are live tell
your friends to give us a call
tune in call in with your questions I'm
Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross good evening
friends and pastor Doug it's good to be
back with a life program we've been gone
for a couple of weeks and we are just
delighted to do this live and our
friends who are listening you're welcome
to call in with your Bible question
number is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven let's start with the word of
Prayer
dear father we thank you that we had
this opportunity once again to open up
your word and study together we do ask
for the Holy Spirit to come and guide us
as we search the Scriptures thank you
for your promise to be with us be with
those who are listening Lord for we ask
this in Jesus name
amen amen well pastor Doug in the age of
computerized shopping in computerized
directions and even to some degree
computerized medical assistance
diagnosis different well why don't have
a computerized pastor that could
sympathize with you and quote scripture
well it seems like some folks are
thinking about that and you don't have
to pay a salary I guess and well you
know there are probably some people in
my church that wish I was a computerized
pastor you know that I think that there
might be something that would be missing
or even maybe even ethically wrong with
it now I've got a confession to make my
my daughter bought me an Alexa which is
you know it's a kind of wireless device
you ask it questions I'm usually saying
things like you know what's the
temperature today and remind me to make
this phone call and but you say yeah you
call out his name you say Alexa and then
you ask a question um what time is
sunset or whatever and she answers you
can even say Alexa you got a joke and
it'll it'll tell you a joke or Alexa
play this music and it plays the music
and and I remember asking the Alexa for
a question and then it told me and I
said thank you I'm so what I'm saying is
a computer it doesn't know and I think
it said you're welcome
and that's boy I think it's going pretty
far you know I really I don't think
we're gonna ever have to worry about a
robot replacing a real person years ago
they had a series called the step where
Stepford Wives that you know someone
would actually develop a robotic husband
or wife you know God made man with the
Holy Spirit there's something different
you can read in the book of Job man it's
not just an automation we have a free
will
there's inspiration where ideas come
that doesn't come necessarily from
pre-programming that they can't even
explain I mean how does Mozart suddenly
know how to do what he did in job 32
verse 8 it says but there is a spirit in
man and the breath of the almighty gives
him understanding and this is talking
about more than just the breath of life
sorry about something about the spirit
that gives him understand
you read in Daniel 5:11 the Queen Mother
said there is a man in your kingdom in
whom is the spirit of the holy God there
is something unique about men and as
intelligent as many animals are no
animal compares with man in just his
ability to communicate to think and
build and live out the abstract in in
imagination and so no I don't think
he'll ever he could you know train a
computer to recite Scripture or maybe
even the computer priest they've got
there in Japan it just is reciting it
goes around on wheels and it recites
pre-programmed prayers but I know what
I'm preaching things come to me that
weren't in my studies and I just saying
all that isn't from me you know God is
speaking
there's something about inspiration now
God is offering that spirit you know
there's a certain breath of life we all
get when we're born but there's a
baptism of the Holy Spirit we must have
when we're born again jesus said unless
you are born of the water water baptism
and the spirit spirit baptism you cannot
enter the kingdom of heaven and we have
a special gift that talks about the
important need of the Holy Spirit we're
going to make available for free to
anyone who asks tonight the book is
called the Holy Spirit the need again
it's called the Holy Spirit the need and
we'll be happy to send this anyone who
calls and asks now we're gonna give you
two numbers the one is the one called if
you have a Bible Christian the other is
our resource phone line and that is 800
eight three five six seven four seven
and that's the number you want to call
and ask for the book called the Holy
Spirit the need the number again is 800
eight three five six seven four seven
and if you have a question the phone
line hit his studio is 800 four six
three seven two nine seven we can we got
our first caller this evening we got
Bill listening in Illinois bill welcome
to the program Oh Pastor John hi thanks
for calling and I hope you don't mind
but I'd like to say hello to Pastor
Barney also oh okay I'm sorry I did not
read this bad I just I've called several
times and I just
I couldn't I researched say India
tonight Barney's the imaginary pastor
but anyway I know what you mean anything
and your question tonight my question is
I bought myself a Bible and I looked
through so many of them and I finally
decided I'm one and I bought it and I
was in the nursing home and when I came
home I started reading it before that I
was reading Bible I'm a audio app so
when I came home I was started in the
New Testament and I read through the
entire New Testament because I had gone
through the Old Testament on my phone
and I started over again after I was
through with the New Testament I started
reading through it a second time and I
get to the Book of Psalms and it goes
from Psalms 89 to Psalms 116 it's
missing like a dozen pages so I called a
college company and they said oh don't
worry we have a lifetime guarantee on
our Bibles and we'll be happy to send
you a new one we'll send you a form to
fill out send it back to us we'll send
your new Bible so when I got the form
Bible set form says that they want me to
tear out all the copyright pages in the
Bible and send them to them and they
won't take photocopy it has to be the
actual pages and so I wanted to know
would that be like vandalizing God's
Word to rip pages out of the Bible all
right now if a person that's a good
question I can understand you would
think that doing something like that
might be on the borders of doing
something sacrilegious if you've got a
defective Bible you know there's some
Bibles actually I've had to throw out
Bibles just because they get torn and
old or you got left out in the rain
there got caught in the rain they swell
up they're useless
you know Bible is sacred when you're
reading the word the book itself is ink
on paper the Spirit gives those words
life if a person was just trying to be
evil and desecrate a Bible that would be
wrong but if you've got a defective book
that's in the printing and the
publishers are saying as opposed to
shipping the whole Bible back which is
heavy send us a copy write pages so that
we know that you bought it what version
it was the
nothing wrong with that then you can you
know reverently dispose of that Bible
after the issue your your new one and
usually for the pages that have the
copyright information on that they
separate pages they don't typically have
Bible text printed on those pages it's
just the front section you have to take
out I think that would be fine yeah yeah
I can understand I appreciate that I
heard about a man that was in jail in
China someone brought him a Bible well
he wasn't at all religious but he did
smoke cigarettes and he couldn't get any
cigarette papers so he started tearing
out the onion thin pages of the Bible
and using them as cigarette papers but
he thought well this is a religious book
I should probably be reading it while I
smoke it so whenever he got ready to
smoke a cigarette he thought I better
read the page first cuz I'll never see
it again he'd read it and then he'd roll
the cigarette and smoke it you know
somewhere around Exodus he got converted
he was doing something we don't
recommend but you know God can even use
that hey thank you so much for your
question bill we appreciate it
you know we do have a book talking about
the Bible it's called the ultimate
resource and sometimes people have
questions about where did the Bible come
from I had our read or study the Bible I
think you'll find this book very
interesting it's called the ultimate
resource and if you'd like to get a copy
of that the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and ask for the book called the
ultimate resource if you enjoy hearing
solid biblical answers on Bible answers
live you can have those same insights at
your fingertips through the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live
order your copy today at AF bookstore
calm or by calling 1-800 five three
eight seventy two seventy five we've got
Bob listening in Texas Bob welcome to
the program you're on the air
thank you for taking my call mm yes I
had a question about one of the
judgments listed in the Bible and it's
Matthew 25:31 to 46 when and where is
that judgment that's my question okay
this is the parable of the sheep and the
goats yes yeah Christ is talking about
at the very end now in this parable you
got the sheep and the goats representing
the good and the evil of all ages that
have ever lived and that would be at the
end of the 1,000 years it's like the
great white throne judgment at the end
of the millennium when everybody who has
ever lived his present and accounted for
you know ultimately the saved he says
well done good and faithful servants
enter into the joy of the Lord they are
given permanent access to the New
Jerusalem whereas the wicked are being
told they are forever
cast out they go off into the lake of
fire and the result of their punishment
is eternal they don't get a second
chance that would be the judgment at the
end of the 1,000 years are there any
definite clues that put it at that time
if then a the texts around it look like
they have to be about the Lord's second
coming well the reason we think it's at
the you know first of all if you look in
Revelation 21 you find the Millennium
and it tells us that the at the end of
that 1000 years Satan is ultimately and
his angels cast into the lake of fire
you have that happening in verse 41 says
this everlasting fire prepared for the
devil and his angels
in Revelation that's at the end of the
millennium could we send you a study on
that we've got a study that talks about
the Millennium in this judgment and it's
got all the verses sure what you need to
ask for Bob is just simply a study guide
called a thousand years of peace a
thousand years of peace it's all about
the Millennium the number to call is 883
five six seven four seven 883 five six
seven four seven ask for the study guide
called a thousand years of peace you can
also read this online just go to the
amazing facts website it's amazing facts
to our G we have chaste listening in
Houston Texas chase welcome to the
program good evening Pastor John pastor
Doug how are you good hi doing good
thanks for calling thanks for taking my
call
so I recently started reading Ezekiel
and in Chapter one it starts out as
equals having a vision and he sees these
four creatures and and then he sees I
believe it's in first fifteen he sees
these wheels and they start interacting
with these wheels and I'm having a hard
time understanding what these wheels are
can you help me with that
well I'll do my best but you might have
to get in line because it's probably one
of the most mysterious apocalyptic
prophecies the the answer that I've
heard a professor he was talking about
how life we've learned now in many ways
is a wheel within a wheel and of course
it looks like this power these wheels
within the wheels the creatures are you
know mobile he could look at a an Abrams
tank and a track that drives a tank is a
wheel within a wheel but I don't think
the these angelic creatures are going
around like that keep in mind the
creatures are symbolic in Ezekiel and in
Revelation when it's talking about
dragons with seven heads and the sum of
these things there's symbolism there but
the symbolism of the wheel and the wheel
our solar system is a series of wheels
within a wheel a cell of life is a wheel
within a wheel we just see even atoms
and neutrons and electrons just in the
whole universe there's this there's this
order of things and it's almost like you
know Ezekiel is is seen as power of life
so it's it's something of a mystery I
don't know pastor Ross you got yeah yeah
again it's a symbolic picture but it one
explanation I've already is also
illustrating the mobility where God is
all-knowing
is all seeing these four living
creatures that make his throne they can
move to the left the right forward back
and God knows what's going on he's very
much aware he's not limited to a
particular place but he's aware of
what's happening it's that's one
explanation on the wheels representing
mobility yeah and even maybe more
telling is the four creatures you see
there in Ezekiel are identical to the
four creatures you see in Revelation 4
that the same phases okay you know we'd
like to carry a book on that but I've
not seen anything that really unpacks
that as well as I'd like it's something
of a mystery oh I appreciate your
insight thank you very much all right
hey thanks a lot appreciate your call
next caller that we have is Becky
listening from Michigan Becky welcome to
the program oh how are you doing doing
well how can we help you tonight Vickie
my mom is in the hospital and it's just
a lot of things are conflict here right
now and I'm a little upset a little
lonely so when you're feeling lonely and
you're wondering what you can do well of
course we'll be praying for you and your
mom as far as an answer would go the
Bible tells us to cast our cares upon
the Lord now can you imagine God in
heaven pacing the floor and wringing his
hands looking worried or can you imagine
God perspiring with concern you know our
God's the veins standing out on his
forehead as he's worried about a
situation God is the quintessence of
peace he doesn't worry about anything
when you cast your cares on him and he
sees the beginning from the end you know
that he has a thousand answers to
whatever your your heartache and your
loneliness is now that you don't know
anything about and he says I never leave
you or forsake you
you know David in Psalm 23 says even
though you go through the valley of the
shadow of death the Lord is with you
keep in mind you don't stop in the
valley it's something that God has to
bring us through there are gonna be
challenges in life there's gonna be
shadows but they're temporary you go
through them with the Lord so just stay
close to Jesus and you'll
he'll help bring you through that okay
Becky okay thank you
god bless you God bless you and we'll be
thinking of you and your mom I'm just
thinking pastor day if we have a book
dealing with that I think we had one
cold when the brook dries up I'm not
sure if we still carry that one that
might have encouragement talking about
going through trials the difficulties
and back if you'd call our resource
phone line that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven and after the book
called when the brook dried up and
you'll be able to I will send it to you
for free you'll be able to read and I
think you'll find comfort and
encouragement through trials and
difficulties you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
Time call us at one eight hundred seven
[Music]
distinct in georgetown guyana
it looks like richard walked to the
program yes good evening and thanks for
taking my call
yes sir we appreciate it as i read the
bible i realize some of these men of god
they would have had several ways I don't
see any whereas it been condone any way
however what I would like to know if in
these days a guy can't commit adultery
with his first wife
you know let's see it was married he's
now divorced and he has another wife and
then he has an affair with his first
wife
how would that situation be unfolded in
the in terms of adultery it was always
his wife issue always his wife
all right good question you know there's
actually verse in pastor Ross might help
me find it in Deuteronomy where Moses
said that if a man divorces his wife and
gives her a certificate of divorce 'men
and he goes and he marries another woman
that he cannot go back to his first wife
lest the land be defiled the Bible does
specifically address
that God didn't want the children of
Israel to say well I'm not sure I'm
happy with my first wife
I'm gonna divorce her marry another wife
well the grass wasn't really any greener
I guess I'll go back to my first wife
may God said no you can't do that well
once someone had given his wife a
certificate of divorcement they were to
take that very seriously and it was to
be considered permanent yeah it would be
considered adultery once you've divorced
your wife she is no longer your wife to
go back to her again is adultery
especially if you're married to somebody
else and I don't know if your pastor
Ross is probably looking about yeah
that's it I I know it's in Deuteronomy
and I gave you a pretty good quote on it
just from memory sometimes as you get
older you can't remember the chapter and
verse the passage is Deuteronomy chapter
it starts in around verse 1 and goes
through to verse 3 and it addresses that
so Deuteronomy 24 is the chapter all
right Richard hope that helps a little
bit and we do have a book we can offer
on marriage yes called marriage divorce
and remarriage and we'll be happy to
send in to anyone who wants to learn
more about what the Bible says about
marriage and remarriage the number is
883 five six seven four seven and you
can ask for the book called marriage
divorce and remarriage next one of the
we have easi Frank listening from New
York you Frank welcome to the program
good evening pastor doug in pastor ross
evening yes i would just like to state
the that you know i recently last 72
hours lost a fellow friend of mine who
was a financial secretary of my
religious organization and i just wanted
to address this question because it's a
concern of me because this happened to
have happened besides the death about
approximately three weeks ago a reverend
minister of the word who was visiting
our church here in queens from the
continent of africa who is in 1976
world olympiad from the world tennis
team he indicated that he was concerned
about what's going on in the world
especially right now in this time period
because he got nervous when he saw that
the sky was turning on a blue cloudless
day in New York City was completely an
entirely dark on a Monday morning when
there was reports of an asteroid coming
approximately 12,000 miles from the
sun's orbit into the earth as you might
have heard that that that did occur and
he was very nervous are you was he
wondering if there is there anything in
the Bible about the astronomical
phenomenon he was concerned that it
could be from the seven plagues and the
seven bowls and I tried to calm him down
to tell him that maybe it's not that
it's just that those are astronomical
anomalies that do happen from time to
time okay good all right so I think I
understand yeah there the Bible tells us
that you know there of course God made
the Sun Moon and stars and and we have
shooting stars that are even mentioned
in the Bible talks about falling stars
he may have been referring to one of
those seven plagues are where and the
trumpets I think also talk about a fiery
rhyming star yeah down down is that nine
revelation nine revelation 9 yeah some
people have wondered if that burning
star coming down in Revelation 9 is that
an asteroid striking the earth or and I
think it mentioned something similar in
the trumpets you know there there have
been comments there sometimes God shows
signs and the Sun Moon and stars as
recently as yesterday I was reading
Josephus the historian who talked about
the fall of Jerusalem and he said there
were signs in the heavens
you know sometimes God may give
astronomical phenomenon to be harbingers
of
things coming but I'm not qualified as a
prophet to say what that one asteroid
meant I mean there Halley's Comet comes
every 70 72 years well you know we do
have some prophetic specific moments
when we do have mentioned Matthew 24
talks about a time period when the stars
will fall from heaven and this the moon
has the appearance of blood and the Sun
is darkened and we know these from
certainty star
the currents back in 1833 there was
what's a tremendous meteor shower across
North America and people recognized that
as could possibly be a fulfillment of
this verse but this does occur again
just before Jesus comes in quick
succession yeah I probably would not I
would think that God would do something
more dramatic we had a shooting star or
a meteorite that struck the atmosphere
over Sacramento this year I believe it
was and all these people took pictures
and said what was that you know and it
changes the atmosphere briefly when it
does it so that's happening they had one
that we struck Russia quit it a metaphor
the one that hit Russia well about four
or five years ago created quite a boom
and broke windows and some people were
actually burnt by the flash this one in
New York I don't know that it was the
most prominent astronomical sign well we
appreciate your question your call a
Frank we're gonna take a break here in a
moment and we'll get on with more calls
we do have other lines open call us 800
God says 800 God says and in the
meantime don't forget you can see so
much more on the website amazing facts
to our G we'll be right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation and even discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
earth every life the cosmic conflict if
God is good if God is all-powerful if
God is love
then what went wrong for life-changing
Christian resources visit a F bookstore
calm or call one eight hundred five
three eight seven two seven five one to
know God's plan for our world and
solutions for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
calm or by calling 858 seven two seven
five written by the hand of God and
spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 to 75 or visit AF bookstore
com every Bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of God's will for your life
so what are you waiting for
get the answers you need for a fuller
richer more confident life you're
listening to Bible answers live this
broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
simple setup until we get into the
studio and that's just that the amazing
facts or doug batchelor facebook page
and i am doug batchelor
my name is john ross and be good to go
to the next phone phone call we got Phil
listening in New York so welcome to the
program yes thank you very much thanks
for taking my call could you hear me
okay loud and clear okay great
my question is this you can go to the
web right now and see at least a half a
dozen websites by apparently
authoritative people archeologists all
of whom say the same thing as Solomon
temple is not in that plateau behind the
where you find the the Dome of the rock
but it was in the City of David that is
very interesting because it would appear
if that is confirmed that would appear
to open the door to the possibility of a
third Jewish temple so I wonder what do
you think about that well I've heard
that before I've been to Israel three
times
and traveled with some pretty
well-educated scholars and they were all
all that I spoke to were and I've been
to where the City of David excavations
are going on always stopped and looked
at that it's remarkable what they're
finding but there is no area there that
is big enough to accommodate the roughly
13 acres that Solomon had under his
temple and the great patio on the porch
that are spoken of there in second Kings
our first King sorry so I'm still you
know I could be wrong but I'm still
inclined to think that the the location
on Mount Moriah where the western wall
is is where Abraham offered Isaac and
it's where ultimately they called it the
threshing floor of Ornan where David had
the temple built okay thank you very
much for your pain I appreciate it
thanks for listening to my question all
right thank you so much bye-bye
have you ever wondered how can I share
Jesus with my Jewish friends amazing
faxes recently produced a fascinating
three-part DVD series called is Jesus
kosher for Jews in these new programs
three Jews Steve Wahlberg Jeff sir
Minsky and myself relate our personal
encounter with a Christian faith so pick
up a copy today for yourself and share
one with your Jewish friends call 800
538 7275
or visit us at AF bookstore com to get
yours next caller that we have is Matt
listening in Sacramento Matt welcome to
the program
hi Matt are you still there might have
your mute on Matt Matt are you there
hello yeah Matt you're on the air oh
sorry I was I'm from Michigan Michigan
oh okay sorry we've got a little mix-up
they're on our phone lines and your
question yeah it's on Revelation 1313
King that fire that comes down is it
possible that's more of a symbolic kind
of a meaning of like a false gods
acceptance or a sending of a false
spirit it is possible in the Bible when
it talks about fire coming down it was
often an indicator of God's favor when
you know Abel offered his sacrifice God
accepted it
he did not accept the sacrifice of Cain
when Moses consecrated the temple in the
wilderness fire came down from heaven
fire sometimes came down from heaven as
a judgment as it did with the sons of
Aaron and later it came down in the time
of Elijah as a judgment but it also came
down sometimes as a sign of God
accepting the sacrifice
when it says bringing fire down from
heaven that's something that only God
typically did as one time in the book of
Job it looks like the devil brought fire
down from heaven otherwise it was always
God so it could be telling us in
Revelation 13 that Satan is going to
seek to counterfeit the power of God or
the you know looks like the acceptance
of God now some people used to say well
that's an atomic bomb fire coming down
from heaven I don't think so I think
it's talking about counterfeit Holy
Spirit or imitating the power of God you
pastor also you get any thoughts on that
yeah I was just gonna add a little more
you got fire coming down from heaven in
the book of Acts the Holy Spirit came
upon the disciples in the form of
tongues of fire and I think in
Revelation in particular there is a
counterfeit of the Holy Spirit that
takes place at the end and these
so-called miracles and signs that appear
and that helps to galvanize those who
are opposed to the truth of God's Word
and obedience to the commandments in the
last days and so the fire coming out
from heaven in Revelation 1330 is
talking about this counterfeit spirit
this counterfeit movement
last days and the Bible warns about it
absolutely does that help a little bit
yeah yeah you'd probably enjoy the we do
have a book on the Holy Spirit will send
your free copy it's part of tonight's
offer it's called simply life the need
Holy Spirit the need and so it's called
we have another one called life we're
not live in the spirit but just after
the one called the Holy Spirit the need
the number to call for that is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and you can ask for the book
called the Holy Spirit the need our next
call is Carl listening from Canada Carl
welcome to the program good night
gentlemen thanks for taking my call yes
sir how can we help you yes my question
is in respect of Luke 22:36 I was
listening to what may have been a
religious broadcast and these gentlemen
were saying that Luke 22:36
means that Jesus wanted his disciples to
be armed it says something about selling
your cloak and buying a sword isn't a
literal sword or is he talking about the
world with symbolic language as opposed
to literally them arming themselves with
the weapons of the day all right a good
question and let me read this for our
friends Christ is speaking and I'll
start with verse 37 he said I say to you
that which is written is going to be
accomplished well I'm sorry let me go to
36 but now he who has no money let him
take it and likewise a knapsack and he
who has no sword let him sell His
garment and buy one and then in verse 30
the disciple said look Lord here are two
swords and he said to them it is enough
now the way that really translates from
the Greek is Jesus said enough of this
when Christ was saying sell his garment
by a sword he wasn't recommending that
the disciples arm themselves because
later when Peter pulls out a sword and
that's in Matthew I think yeah he says
put your sword away he that lives by the
sword will perish by the sword Jesus
told him not to use swords so what does
it mean when he said he that has a
garment let him sell it by a sword
even do everything you can to arm
yourself with the Word of God Christ
said I did not come to send peace but a
sword and he meant that the sword
sometimes the Word of God divides the
Word of God is quick and powerful and
sharper than any two-edged sword so the
question is what does Jesus mean in
verse 38 and that's in Luke Shawn
22 when they said look Lord we have two
swords and he said it is enough he said
it enough of this you don't get it for
example Jesus takes the disciples he's
going across the Sea of Galilee and he
said beware of the leaven of the
Pharisees and they said oh man we forgot
lunch again
what's he talking about Jesus said you
don't get it I'm not talking about bread
I'm not talking about lunch I'm talking
about the teachings of the Pharisees so
Jesus sometimes speaks in metaphors he
was speaking in a metaphor here he
wasn't suggesting that we take up swords
if Jesus wanted us to take swords and
defend him he wouldn't have given
himself he would have used his own power
to defend himself he wouldn't have told
the disciples put away your swords so
yeah I am pretty certain that Jesus here
is speaking in a symbolic term now
that's this is a whole different issue
of is it wrong or right for a Christian
to own a weapon to defend their home I'm
just saying in this verse to say that
Jesus was telling Christians arm
yourself I don't think that's what this
verse is all about matter of fact a
little later on you read about the time
Peter did take out his sword to try and
fight off the Romans that came to rest
Jesus and G Jesus said put away the
sword he who lives by the sword shall
die by the sword so he's not telling
disciples to get weapons for some sort
of an assault on the Romans yeah alright
hey thank you so much Carl appreciate
your question tonight I hope that helps
a little bit
what if you could know the future
but what you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfilment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com next go to
the baby's Patrick listening in
Massachusetts Patrick welcome to the
program Oh pastor Ross how are you guys
good good I listen to your show all the
time and I've always given everybody
your channel no matter where I go as
well as sharing the gospel well thank
you and the one that really like is the
cosmic conflict and the pride the beasts
of everyone that really well good that's
something that I really needed to hear
and to share that to other people
hi have you seen or just why we're on it
did you see our latest DVD called
kingdoms in time yes I got that one yes
sweetie when you guys gotta know yeah I
got that right away yeah that's it
that's awesome I like that all right
great and your question I got my family
in Philippines that when you guys with
the Irish here has done your channel as
well amen amen
the question is I was leaving on the
Bible and I came across to Matthew
chapter 19 verse 9 and I believe it says
that if you it says that if you divorce
your wife for anything other than sexual
immorality and you marry another commits
adultery so I'm in the bind now because
I divorced my wife for not for sexual
immorality but for something else
but now I'm currently married to my wife
for three years and I stumbled to this
and I'm like uh-oh I'm in big trouble
what do I do
well you know I can't comment on whether
you had biblical grounds for your first
divorce or remarriage
you're really saying what do I do now
you we read a scripture earlier tonight
in Deuteronomy that says if you've
divorced your first wife and you've
remarried you can't now divorce your
present wife and go back to your first
wife what do you do like take the story
of King David David does something he
sins he commits adultery with Bathsheba
then he kind of has her husband killed
and then he marries her and then he's
confronted with what he's done so what's
he supposed to do now divorced Bathsheba
and leave her a widow no he kept her as
his wife he repented of his sin and I
heard a pastor say one time you cannot
unscramble scrambled eggs
you know sometimes you've made a mistake
and you can't you know you just have to
pray that God will forgive there's going
to be consequences for all of our
decisions we make but you can't always
untangle those or knots it's like they
say you know you just you love your
present wife try to be a faithful
Christian husband learn from any
mistakes of the past
if you have children from your former
marriage you need to care for them but
you need to move on where you are where
you are now you know we have a book that
does address this called marriage
divorce and remarriage and I think
you'll find that helpful Patrick all
you'll have to do is give us a call on
our resource phone line the number is
883 five six seven four seven and you
can ask for the book on marriage divorce
and remarriage and it gives you all the
different Bible texts relating to the
subject I think you'll find it helpful
again 800 eight three five six seven
four seven we've got Tom listening in
South Carolina Tom welcome to the
program hi how are you I'm doing okay my
question is I I retired from my
part-time job in a grocery store
I would hundred hours a month
and my question is I pay tithes but I
don't pay offering anymore because I
didn't have the money and I was
wondering should we pay the offering
like I gave to you folks and I gave a
couple other things should we continue
paying offering and let God supply or
should we not pay anything
well of course you're making the right
decision to faithfully return your tithe
there's a promise in Malachi chapter 3
that if we bring our tithes into the
storehouse that God will open the
windows of heaven and pour out a
blessing and bless sometimes we don't
know how he's gonna do that and he
surprises us every time I God promises
if we're faithful that he will take care
of us now I can't tell you you know what
you should do as far as offering is
concerned but there in Malachi it says
bring the tithes and offerings into the
storehouse you're gonna you know tie
this a specified amount God says a tenth
of your increase offerings is different
it's something that each man purposes in
his heart as it says and I think it's
first Corinthians yeah you know what you
might try put God to the test he the
Lord says in Malachi chapter eight he
says prove me you might try just say
alright Lord I don't know how I'm gonna
afford it but I'm gonna I'm gonna make
an offering this month to my church or
wherever you choose and say Lord are you
gonna now bless the remainder and see if
God does something extraordinary for you
to supply now we also have you know we
have a free lesson we can send you Tom
on the subject of tithes and offerings
it's called
In God We Trust and we'd be willing to
send that to you free or anyone who
wants more information on this subject
and the reference that you referring to
second Corinthians chapter 9 verse 7
talks about laid each one give as he
purposes in his heart not grudgingly or
of the necessity for God loves a
cheerful Giver and if you'd like to get
that study guide talking about
and money and what the Bible says the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
that is the resource phone line and just
asked for the study guide called
In God We Trust and we're happy to send
that to anyone who calls and asks we've
got Robert listening from Walla Walla
Washington Robert welcome to the program
hello pastor Roz hi yeah there Robert
Robert in Walla Walla are you there
he may have hit the mute button it looks
like you're still on but we don't hear
you let's try one more time
hello yep we can hear you now and your
question yeah I just the thing welcome
back well thank you
last time we talked we talked about the
spirit and how its breath uh-huh I just
was wanting to know that's not the same
thing as in first Peter 3:18 though is
it where there are spirits in prison
that Jesus is preaching to correct
it is different there's times and you
have to read the context when he talks
about spirits in prison he's talking
about people he's not talking about
breath in prison he's talking about
those who lived in the days before Noah
that God through the spirit spoke to
them it says when once the
long-suffering of God waited in the day
of Noah you know there's a few times
where the word spirit is used to talk
about individuals just like you know
there's even some times where the word
soul is used not talking about a
person's spirit or a person even an
animal that means a mean life says all
the souls in the sea died and you're
talking about first Peter chapter 3
verse oh roughly 18 through 22 right and
can you name any verses that talk about
a human being a spirit be besides that
one I think oh one verse talks about the
spirit that is a man those the thoughts
of man yeah I actually I think I read
one tonight in the beginning of the
program where I was talking about Jobe
it says there is a spirit in man and the
breath of the almighty gives him
understanding well there there it's not
just the breath it's talking but he's
got understanding oh yes this several
actually I mean you're looking proverbs
I'm just I looked up
written says this word of man will
sustain him in sickness but he who but
who can bear a broken spirit and then it
talks about a man's pride will bring him
low but a humble spirit will retain on
us so the word spirit is used in
different contexts
right and I think even Paul talks about
the mind in the spirit mm-hmm yeah
sometimes it's this ethereal essence of
God in man we do have a book maybe
Robert has read that already where we
talk about the dead are they really dead
and it talks about the three definitions
for the Holy Spirit in Hebrew and Greek
yes if you'd like to receive that anyone
Robert or anyone listening just call our
resource phone line the number again is
883 five six seven four seven ask for
the study guide entitled are the dead
really dead again 880 three five six
seven four seven we've got neck
listening from Michigan Nick welcome to
the program hi can you hear me okay
really well it's like you're in the next
room and your question yeah I have a
friend who's struggling with the whole
concept of Jesus being God and also
being the Son of God and like being the
same as God you know all that so can you
like explain it well there's some
mystery to it so I won't pretend that I
can explain it at all because the Bible
talks about the Incarnation is some
somewhat mysterious but I can show you
scriptures that tell us that Jesus is
God first of all the Bible says in the
beginning God created the heavens and
the earth so everyone agrees that's the
big God that made everything then you go
to the New Testament it says that all
things were made through christ the word
so if God made everything in the
beginning and then it says that all
things are made through the word or
Jesus Jesus must be God Bible says only
God knows the thoughts of men's hearts
but it tells us Jesus knew what was in
man several times Jesus read the minds
of the people that were around him and
told him what they were thinking if only
God can do that then Jesus must be God
the Bible tells us that there is only
one Savior that is God well Jesus is a
savior he must be God Bible tells us we
should
ship god only god it's a one of the 10
commandments tells us even the angels
worship Jesus
well if Jesus received worship from
angels and humans and God says we should
only worship God he must be God so as
you go through the Bible and you look at
all the definitions of God Jesus it can
be dropped right into all of those
definitions thank you that makes a lot
of sense no I've got a book that day I
mean I just gave you the when you call
it the thumbnail sketch the tip of the
iceberg I like you send your free book
on that and it's a new book I just wrote
on the Trinity so if you ask for my new
book on the Trinity it I have a whole
section that talks about is Jesus God
then I'm gonna call for that e is 883
five six seven four seven and again just
after the book on the Trinity I think
it's called the Trinity is it biblical
something like that well yeah we got our
three one okay we got two books one god
of three and the number to call it's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven we have Wade calling from
North Dakota Wade welcome to the program
yes Martha thank you yes for taking my
question my question is is how do we
distinguish between promises and
statements and then between the Old
Testament New Testament with the Malachi
one there's one there in Ephesians where
it says God is able able to above and
beyond do anything that you ask or think
of now it is that just a statement that
doesn't say he will how do you
distinguish between promises and
statements when you have a specific
situation and you're looking for
scriptures and everybody says well you
can claim the promises well okay he
promised the Israelis that he would get
him out of Egypt after for a hundred
years so I doesn't apply to me but 50
huh right well in a sense it does he is
he in a way he saved them from Egypt he
saves us from the slavery to sin he
delivered them from the Pharaoh he
delivers us from the devil and they went
through the Red Sea and we get baptized
and then they were baptized in a pillar
of fire were baptized in the holy spirit
so the whole Exodus experience actually
has a great analogy for salvation
but back to your question yeah first of
all there are a number of promises in
God that don't become valid like a check
unless you take it to the bank so if you
are praying and you need you know some
special help and like when God says he's
exceedingly able to help you abundantly
above all that you could ask or think
you can get on your knees by your bed
open your Bible put your finger on that
verse and say Lord I got a problem can
you help me with this and and I've I've
always seen God to come through when he
makes a promise in his word if we meet
the conditions you know there's a Bible
says if we're turning away our ear from
hearing his law then our prayer is an
abomination
he doesn't promise carte blanc answers
to people that are living in known
rebellion if we surrender to the Lord
and and we love him the Bible says
whatsoever things we ask we receive of
him because we keep his Commandments and
do those things that are pleasing in his
sight a lot of promises Peter says and I
forget where it is I read it this week
exceeding precious promises that by
these we might become partaker of the
divine nature yeah just a lot of a lot
of promises in the word that's 2nd Peter
chapter 1 verse 4 2nd Peter 1:4 there's
a promise right there well and you
memorize the promises of God you know
what I you know almost hate to admit
this but I've been surprised when you
just go to like even google and you type
in Bible promises on this or that it
categorizes them and it gives you a list
of 40 Bible promises unforgiveness 50
Bible promises it's on this so that so
many people have done Studies on this
that it's all over the internet you can
find Bible promises in categories just
by searching it and so it's wonderful
then it gives you the scriptures you go
back to your Bible you know we also have
some resources on Bible promises at the
amazing facts or websites just amazing
facts not oh our G so there you go wait
hey I hope that helps a little bit and I
wonder is it still warm in North Dakota
all right who's next pastor oz we have
time for we don't have time we got 30
seconds all right friends that looks
like it's time for us to tell you it's
been a blessing make sure and go to the
Amaze
in fact website and keep tuning in
you're gonna see the studio here where
we're doing the program go through some
transitions we've just moved into some
rooms with sheetrock but it's all
getting unpacked and put together if you
go to amazing facts dot o-r-g you'll be
able to listen to a lot of our Bible
answer programs from before remember
we're all faith-based so we appreciate
whatever you can do to keep us on the
air god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation even discover God's amazing
plan to save his children this is a
story that involves every life on Earth
every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm written by the hand of
God and spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 to 75 or visit AF bookstore
com
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 may sing facts 0 RG
[Music]
you